おむすびころりんある日おじいさんがいつものように山で木の枝を切っていた
お昼ごはんにしようとおじいさんは切り株に腰掛け
おばあさんの握ったおむすびの包みを開いた
するとおブス日が一つ滑り落ちて山の斜面を転がり落ちていく
おじいさんに追いかけるとおむすびが昨日の6
ねもっとに水ターンなに落ちてしまったおじいさんがあのーみると何やら声が動いて
くるかーかうるせえなぁ
家に持ち帰ったっていう話がずらずらと続いていく話でございますいやちょっと待って
よ
をムスビー
そんなに転がったら壊れるんじゃねそう考えた1人の男がいた
こんにちはドクターはじめだ皆さんはおむすびころりんという童話を知っているだろう
か
先ほども話したんですけどもあの爺さんがを結び親まで食べてて落としてコロコロ
コロコロ転がって穴に落ちるというお話でございますそこで私結構あの
おにぎりは生きている家で結構食べてる方だと思うんですけども
おにぎりってこのガレット取ってなるじゃないですか
ボロッとなると思ったんです私はあの動画の中でだからひょっとしたらをニキビをこの
頃だしたらひょっとして割れちゃって穴まで落ちる前にこうれている可能性があるかも
しれないそうなるとこの同案には矛盾が生じていることになります子供には間違っても
むずしたことを押せないようにしていきたいと思っております私流なので今回は
おにぎりを3種類ほど前日して果たして本当に坂からこのを娘
この例にするとこれに2にポってならないかどうかちょっと検証していきたいと思い
ますコンビニの3種類ベーシックねっと準備しました
ファミリーマートローソンセブンイレブン3つのおにぎりを準備しました
ではここ見てもらうと分かると思うんですけども作家になっております車盗んないから
大丈夫だよ
ここからここがしていきます多くまで行ったらさあもう何か僕のイメージだとだいたい
of the week
ローレンした距離はこの距離なんですよおじさんがここでかでおにぎり食って
プロッティ天井型ばあそこまで行ってるイメージを結びがあそこまで壊れずに行ったら
どうあはひとまず
成立この連して方ニーマンしたということの証明になると思われます
これ何しようってんだなではやっていこう最初選手はこちら
ローソンから行けます今袋から出す前に行きますから汚れちゃダメだ
まず何のどうぞよねちょっと花の形が崩れたりするともう会うとそれもを握るとは言い
ませんができます
1 a
にっ
wh
ん
[音楽]
2 tab 3
チョコちゃん持っています
delorean
55中まで来たんですけどもう何だ50がだんだんに壊れている様子は何砂糖でござい
ます続けていきましょう
[音楽]
100が出来ましたまだ全然大丈夫じゃない逆まで行ってもまだ全然大丈夫ですもう
ちょっとフォローがしていきました
[音楽]
187188て完璧や190
25鉄球色気190し190初
鉄球時給200円さあ
壊れないよいやこれないですねまだ全部で回転しますしもうせて咲かが終わりますこの
まま入っちゃいましょう
[音楽]
需給300あ
300行きました
群像301302303
304300も306高めるなら
1年はへ307回転がした主婦に切りです
外処バレるんじゃねセッターでこれ20名行きまーす300発なんですっ
食べてず300事実312
[音楽]
99400400でどう
ちょっと形が崩れてきているもう一所へ行きます
[音楽]
小屋からん
なるほどねー1000回転くらいはいきそうですね1000回転ぐらいねー
面白いもんだねぇいいとっ姉あたらヤバそう
えっ
いろんな風景
それで自分を約3500度これを506
mel
4 e 46616回転目ですそう目月せたるべ
616でしょ3周目いきましょうっちゃっ日
ran t 0 t 人のコンピューター作っんですけ
二月堂
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ
多分壊れないずっと回し続けて思ったんですけども回すごとに中で強度が増してって
言うんだよねもつもつしてきてて私飾ったあったがたんだねチェックもんで部分あるん
ですけども
ん
まあローソンのを値切りはけっ
プロリンしても崩れませんあと二つわかんないじゃんねパイロット成分
ひょっとしたら壊れるかもしれないで言っちゃあの2つをやっておきます江藤
ぷっ
th
あっはぁん
[音楽]
ん
bejean ん
関連サーチ309さんで二次完璧です
[音楽]
ん
いただきまーし